sébastien prg randy de 40 sociétés de
lavage auto sur le show deux îlots cars
été créés en 2010 avec un début
d'activité que ces faits en septembre
2010 donc fin d'année les gens ont
choisi nos cars ils peuvent déposer
leurs véhicules à l'atelier on nettoie
et on leur lassitude et que le véhicule
est fini où il peut aller chercher le
véhicule sursis donc on a donc développé
un service voiturier par rapport à ça on
va prendre le véhicule du client on peut
qu'il ait pas un endroit adapté pour la
baie de véhicules on va récupérer le
vécu dans la zone autour d'ateliers
saisir sainte-marie chaudron saint
claude thin etc on prend le véhicule du
client l'emmène à l'atelier on le ramène
on est assuré tous risques au chauffeur
le client on sorte son boulot il a une
voiture propre et les contraintes unités
mobiles toutes équipées qui vient chez
le client le pire on fournit de
l'électricité on à son équipe sur place
s'évacuer nos cars est une petite
structure on a démarré tout doucement au
début j'avais que on n'était que deux
donc un agent et moi même et on a
développé tout doucement en acquérant
nouvelles compétences notamment dans le
domaine du titanic c'est un domaine qui
se développe énormément à travers le
monde c'est vraiment eu lavage dans les
détails on va enlever les micros rayures
les petites tâches dans les coins on va
rouvrir les joints des véhicules on va
traiter les véhicules etc
en 2015 on va recruter un donc un
nouveau technicien lavage auto nouveau
préparateur automobile donc en termes de
profil
il serait souhaitable d'avoir quelqu'un
qui des compétences dans le domaine de
peinture parce que c'est vrai que
l'activiste développe dupuch goldstein
donc connaître déjà avoir de bonnes
bases enfin tueur notamment on aura des
traitements qui vont arriver d'ici 2015
qu'ils appliquent au pistolet à peinture
donc déjà quelques des confidences de la
peinture qu'elle soit minutieuse et
quels qu'ils soient ponctuels et
quelqu'un qui a envie de de partir d'une
nouvelle aventure et
intégrez une équipe solide on passe
toujours par une période de cdd pour les
nouvelles embauches et de cars si la
personne est et a fait ses preuves ça se
sache ça se transforme constamment par
un ciné
le technicien de lavage et préparateur
auto doit maîtriser les connaissances de
base en mécanique automobile être doté
d'un bon esprit d'analysé de réflexion
et d'observation
faire preuve d'habileté et de précision
dans ses gestes
savoir s'adapter aux évolutions
technologiques
pour avoir notamment aux petites fibres
où on n'est pas à se dire ah c'est pas
grave le véhicule il est propre le pied
on verra pas
proposer un service de qualité qui sont
encore une fois différente de ce qu'on
propose ans à son service